Earth observation satellites orbit between
111 miles and 1,243 miles above the surface...
so HOW THE HECK can they spot the car in my
driveway?!
Hey y'all, Trace here for your Weekly DNews
Space Update!
There's this amazing political commitment
called the International Charter on Space
and Major Disasters.
The Charter was created after the UNISPACE
III conference in 1999 as a framework for
sharing of satellite data amongst member states
in the case of disaster.
Pretty much all of the satellite operating
countries are members.
China activated The Charter after the Malaysian
Airlines Boeing 777 disappeared.
Once activated, member agencies determine
which satellites can be tasked with shooting
pictures of the area of interest, usually
a location of a tsunami, earthquake and so
on.
This is the first time the Charter's been
activated to hunt track down a missing airliner!
Conspiracy theorists assume spy satellites
can zoom in and read over your shoulder, but
the Earth is real big y'all.
Anyone who's used Google Earth knows this,
you can spend days on there.
But how does a thing 1200 miles a way make
out a tiny airplane, or a car in my driveway?
Back in the day, the recently de-classified
Gambit and Hexagon American spy satellites
used large format film dropped from space
and developed on the ground.
The chemical process of film is SUPER clear,
but limited to the number of rolls of film
blasted off with the satellite.
Digital camera technology exists in part BECAUSE
of the space program's want for digital images.
Three companies GeoEye, DigitalGlobe and Spot
Image employ about a dozen satellites just
for ground imaging.
Governments, agencies and private companies
have their own camera-equipped satellites,
but the specs are a secret.
The GeoEye-1 says they can capture 700-million
pixels-per-second with a black and white resolution
of 16 inches per pixel.
The most famous, Earth-imaging satellites
are the Keyhole series.
They're probably the best, and some version
has been orbiting for more than three decades.
The KH satellite is basically a giant orbiting
lens.
They're like the Hubble Telescope, but instead
of pointing at far-away galaxies, they're
pointing at terrorists, enemies of the state,
and that little red book you're reading in
the park.
HowStuffWorks says the KH series can use it's
camera to see things as small as FIVE INCHES
per pixel, so they can't tell WHAT book you're
reading, but they can see the book.
When it comes to spotting VERY specific things,
things get tough.
The lenses and digital cameras inside the
satellites have to point at the right place
at the right time.
So if you're worried someone is spying on
you, don't be.
The resources are hard enough to task already.
Not to mention, all this doesn't mean JACK
SQUAT without some SERIOUS data analysis.
There are whole industries built around the
analysis of the images and data from space.
Think about it: 700 megapixels every second
is a lot of visual information, and computers
aren't great at picking out visual details.
With regard to the Malaysia airline, NASA
is looking through the archives of their satellite
data to see if any equipment was over the
area at relevant time.
China's satellites spotted some debris on
Sunday, but small pieces of debris in a constantly
moving ocean are difficult to identify.
So far no one has found anything.
The Internet has been a game changer for this
type of human-centric analysis.
DigitalGlobe has made it's entire library
of relevant photos available to help search
for the missing airplane, and over a hundred
thousand people are helping out.
That's better than a super computer any day.
Are spy satellites nothing to worry about,
or am I underestimating the power of spy agencies?
Tell me your opinion below, and subscribe
for more DNews!